everybody it's gary vaynerchuck Avendano
garyvaynerchuk.com
in a forever period of time I apologize
been hustling being a medium to 110
employees trying to execute instead of
talking so much but you know I've got to
talk once in a while good friend of mine
sent me a Nicki Minaj Google Plus status
update they don't even try it's not
gonna come through but I'll link to it
nicki manaj on her google+ said plus-one
this post and share it and let's see how
far we can go I won't be back until we
reach about how long is it gonna take
people like Nicki Minaj or Nicki Minaj
started Mickey
and by the way humongous fan let me just
prove it maybe I'll get in trouble for
this but I'm gonna play a little you
know starships I'm a fan I'm a huge fan
huge so I wanted this this is probably
not even Nicki this is some social media
consultant that's telling her how to do
it
the thought of brands and people putting
up posts that say let's share this so
it's good for me that people start
following me and my awareness goes up
and if you don't I'm gonna hold you
hostage from me pitching you some more
is insanity celebrities and brands way
too much think that they're bringing
value by spamming and pushing their
content down the consumers throat okay
Nicki here's a little memo why don't you
just shut the [ __ ] up and not talk to us
anymore here's my back you're not gonna
do it because you kind of want to
promote your concerts and your songs and
your other stuff so if we don't get to a
thousand what's gonna happen nothing
because even if it's at 6:56 that we
have no idea what it's up to need to
stick with me here I got a Google+
Google+ be right with you meeting here
too
this um dammit I don't think I'm gonna
find this fast enough for you guys here
real quick give me a second
here's the point and I don't drag it
she's been spamming plenty she's pushing
so must've got to a thousand let me just
see if I can find it Jesus Christ
there's like 40 posts from today by the
way when you go see how many things
Dickie is pushed out in the last two
seconds I Google+ you're gonna kind of
faint fact of the matter is this the
thought of you arbitrage and to get
shares from your community in return for
you to publicly push more promotions is
insane we need to stop the foolishness
it is 2012
Wellum 20 2013 and celebrities and
brands continue to think that their hot
[ __ ] and their content isn't a commodity
you need to respect your fans not this
them